we begin with news from Pakistan where
former prime minister Imran Khan has
been shot and wounded in the leg at a
political rally some of his supporters
are also said to have been injured
footage shared on social media from the
moments after the shooting show Mr Khan
waving to crowds and raving his raising
his fist before being helped into a car
and driven away was leading a march on
the capital Islamabad demanding snap
elections after he was removed from
office in a no-confidence vote this year
we can get more on this now from DW
reporter beanish Javed or welcome Venus
um so I understand Mr Khan has now been
hospitalized what is known of the
shooter oh yeah Imran Khan is
hospitalized as party officials say that
he's in a stable condition uh one
suspect is in the custody and he has
admitted on a on a camera that um his he
only attempted to assassinate Imran Khan
and he uh he he believed that Imran Khan
was misleading the nation and he says
that there was no one behind him but
already uh questions are being raised on
why immediately such a video message was
released by The Suspect and Senior
leadership of Imran Khan's political
party they are pointing fingers at the
government and they are calling it a
planned assassination attempt at Imran
Khan so Shiri mazadi was the former
human rights Minister and a senior
member of Imran Khan's political party
she she tweeted that Rana sanawala who
is the interior minister of the country
threatened to murder Imran Khan and
today we saw him attempt that she also
said the string pullers The
Establishment will also behold
responsible will also be helpless but
the government has said that there will
be a full inquiry yes the government has
condemned it and they are saying that a
thorough investigation
will be carried
and why was he leading this March
towards the capital so Imran Khan was
ousted this year to a no-confidence vote
Imran Khan believes that the military
establishment and his political opinence
collaborated under the with the
influence of the U.S so he believes that
it was illegitimately removed he has the
public support and through this March he
wants his demanding and early election
he believes if there is an early
election
announced he has the public support he
will get the votes and he will become
the prime minister of the country the
new leader right and you mentioned the
the ministry establishment there who who
have often led the country
um what has been his relationship with
them I thought when he was oustered
through the no confidence board he had
he fallen out with he had to fall out
with the military because he believed
that he did not took his side and since
then he has carried out this strong
public narrative against the military
establishment that we have not seen in
Pakistan's history he publicly attacks
them criticizes them so much so that um
the first time in Pakistan's history the
powerful intelligence agency isi its
Chief had to come out publicly conduct a
press conference to clear his position
so clearly right now political tension
is extremely high and it's a very
volatile political situation and so do
we expect it to calm down with the news
of of this inquiry and the news that Mr
Khan's life is is not in danger I don't
think the political situation or the the
tension would decrease I think it would
increase because Imran Khan the way he
is
speaking at the public the way he has
made everyone his enemy uh the state and
the military and the way people are
supporting him right now especially
we've seen in this March I think he if
he gets well soon he will come back he
will lead this March he will go to
Islamabad he will ask for an early
election that means that political
tension will rise and there could
probably be confrontation or probably
violence so I don't see the political
situation getting any a better in the
country right now okay thank you for
that DW reporter Venus Java thank you